Is it over here?
How about over here?
Here!
It's here?
Are you sure it's that one?
Are you sure?
Even in a small amount of disease in a bee colony, Klinker's gonna detect that...
...long before a human would ever detect it.
Klinker inspects bees for the odor of American foulbrood.
It's a very contagious disease that bees get.
Klinker is the only certified dog in the continental United States,...
...probably Alaska and Hawaii, that is certified to detect American foulbrood.
The Maryland Department of Agriculture has had a dog program since '82.
We know the effectiveness of it.
We certainly are going to try to employ more dogs throughout the state...
...to help us be more efficient.
We're gonna go to the next place.
We're gonna go to the next bee yard.
Okay, good girl.
Good job, good job, Klinker.
Good job, yeah.
You did good, girl.